let's bring in karl rove former deputy
chief of staff to president george w
bush and a fox news contributor carl
great to see you i'm kind of reading the
same thing that peter was reading right
there and the way i interpret this he's
talking about an executive order that
will prohibit new investment trade and
financing by u.s persons to and from or
in the so-called dnr and lnr regions of
ukraine which would be luhansk and
doness the breakaway regions of ukraine
is that strong enough carl i mean you're
really putting sanctions on these
breakaway regions and right now leaving
russia pretty much alone
yeah no it's not strong at all it's in
fact it's laughable
this is a moment i hope this isn't all
they're going to do i hope that they are
agreeing upon a set of sanctions that
they can announce that if uh vladimir
putin does sign the documents
recognizing this breakaway region
as an independent region and committing
to russian peacekeepers
that some serious sanctions will be put
in force immediately because this is the
this is the preliminary this is the
opening act if you will of an invasion
of ukraine remember these two regions
uh less than a third of those regions
are now under control of the separatists
and so what they're what the russians
are attempting to do is recognize these
republics give them additional military
support and have them in essence invade
the
ukrainian territory to take the other
two-thirds of these two states
in the eastern part of ukraine these two
regions
away from the ukrainian government and
put them under control of moscow so this
is a pretex pretense to invasion pretext
and we ought to respond strongly to it
yeah and you make a very good point
there carl because ukrainian army forces
do control significant chunks of these
two breakaway territories i want to talk
about diplomacy now i want to play this
sound bite from john kirby and jake
sullivan and then get your response on
the other side
we're absolutely prepared to sit down
and seriously discuss with mr putin a
diplomatic way forward here we will not
close the door on diplomacy we will go
the extra mile on diplomacy but we are
also prepared with our allies and
partners to respond decisively
sure feels like that door is uh getting
near the whole closing carl
well at some point it probably will and
and frankly i think this is this is an
attempt by putin to lay what he
considers to be a quasi-legal predicate
for the invasion of ukraine this is not
a you know this is this is extraordinary
measure he's going to recognize two
breakaway republics that nobody else in
the world recognizes who don't even
control all of the territory and then
they're going to ask for russian troops
to come in and the russians will be in
essence invading the territory of
an independent country ukraine and if we
if we don't recognize that for what it
is which is an invasion and take tough
steps in response we will see more
activity on the part of putin not less
what he recognizes and what he responds
to is strength not weakness and it's
weak for the united states to say we're
not going to allow anybody to to uh in
the it to
you know invest in the eastern region of
of uh of ukraine that will shortly be
under russian control i mean it it's
ridiculous yeah and lastly i mean you
know the eu sounds very much like with
nato you know they are against russia
they they are you know aligned and
they're not budging at all
but will that last i mean if this thing
takes another 10 days to get these
troops in there carl will this alliance
stay intact
you know i think the russians have
miscalculated i think nato has been
strengthened by all this because they
recognize the threat of of russia take
finland for example which during the
entire cold war era was assiduously
neutral between the west and russia the
the leader of finland now says that if
ukraine is invaded finland will consider
asking for membership in nato because he
said our orientation is toward the west
and we we will condemn and uh the the an
invasion of ukraine as as uh by russia
as a hostile act uh on an independent
country this extraordinary and i think a
lot of european capitals
are recognizing putin uh for what he is
which is a thug and they will not stand
for the invasion of ukraine they'll see
it as a threat to themselves
uh carl we will talk to you ahead in the
days coming and we appreciate your
analysis on this thank you sir i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis